hi everyone this is kevin from the chess
website comm and today we're going to be
going over the london system and it's
very solid opening and a lot of players
asked me you know hey kevin I'm new to
chess what is a great opening that I
should start playing with right away
usually I try to tell people find out if
you're aggressive or not aggressive but
today I'm going to go ahead and
recommend the London system for all new
chess players that want to get to the
game and try out a new opening now
that's not to say if you're a you know
experienced chess player this is not a
good opening for you because I think it
can be but the London system really
allows you to develop your pieces early
and correctly and at the same time
you're not going to get any crazy and
wild tactical lines that some of the
other openings that I've discussed will
get into so with that said the opening
starts with pawn to d4 now this is the
London system it's not the London
opening so there are a few variations
that you may see as far as how to come
about these lines and so we'll go over a
few them but the main idea is that your
bishop your dark square bishop is going
to come to f4 early on though maybe not
the second move a lot of times we'll
develop our knight here to f3 first but
our bishop our dark square bishop is
going to come to f4 as you can see early
on this is a little different than what
you may be accustomed to when you play
white most times you develop your light
square bishop first and then you develop
your Knights and get them involved and
usually the last minor piece that you
get involved is your dark square bishop
and a lot of players especially early on
in their chests career will tend not
even to get their dark square Bishop
involved in the game and it becomes the
endgame they realize you know I haven't
even moved
my bishop from this c1 squared so the
London system is very good even for
those players that are experienced but
they say you know what
I'm very good you know playing with
white but I never seem to get my dark
squared Bishop into the game this is
going to get it involved early on so you
may want to take a look at it if you're
one of those players that we just talked
about now from here there are a few
variations you may see from black you
may see pawn to d5 we're going to
develop our Knight to f3 they can now
bring their Knight to f6 and now we're
going to bring our Bishop to f4
now again they don't have to play this
you know if they don't play this they
could play f6 right away and then we
develop our Knight to f3 and they could
from here play ecigs
and then again we're going to bring our
Bishop to f4 or they could try to fit in
Quetta their Bishop to b2 excuse me to
g7 early on they could play g6 right
here and then again we're going to bring
our Bishop to f4 and so these three
moves right here from white are going to
be pretty much the same across the board
pawn to d4 Knight to f3 and Bishop to f4
as you can see from black here a lot of
times with this opening black will play
some sort of a Kings Indian defense and
the London system in itself plays really
well against the London defense and why
is that so a player that's playing a
Kings Indian defense is really looking
to build up the defense a hyper modern
defense and then attack the center or
attack some sort of weakness that white
hats
what White's really doing in the London
system it's not really attacking one
side or the other it's really just
building up all his pieces and
developing them into the center and then
kind of trying to strangle all the
blacks opportunities in the middle and
not really allowing black any counter
play in the chess game at all so that's
why it usually works well against the
king and in the fence because by the
time black is ready to counter-attack
there's no room for them to move and so
that usually works out really well for
white now from here once we have our
dark square Bishop out we can bring our
pawn to e3 obviously we want to bring
our dark square Bishop out before we
block it in with our pawn to e3
eventually we'll bring our pawn to c3
and we're kind of going to solidify our
pawn chain here in the middle now these
pawns here eventually on e3 and c3 are
not directly you know attacking the
center or controlling the center but
again we are just building a solid
Center control with our ponds and then
eventually we can continue to develop
our minor pieces a lot of times we'll
bring our our LightSquared Bishop to d3
and we'll bring our other night here to
d2 so these are just some of the ideas
that you'll want to think about when you
play the London system now keep in mind
a lot of times you may not even Castle
your King when you play the London
system keep in mind that you castle for
a few reasons one you obviously want to
connect your rooks but the second is you
really want to have King safety also in
the end the London system your Center is
actually going to be one of the safest
places on the board so a lot of times
experienced london system players will
develop all their minor pieces and then
instead of castling able to start to
attack maybe the king side
instead of castling on the queenside
they will just start to move their king
up the board trying to get their king
centralized if they do go into the
endgame and the rooks are already going
to be connected as their minor pieces
are already developed also want to go
over a famous game by kabocha vic who
wrote a book on the london system it was
played in 1980 and it kind of goes over
a lot of the concepts and themes that
we've kind of been talking about so
starts with pawn to d4 Knight f6 Knight
f3 pawn to b5 Bishop to f4 and then pawn
to e6 again very common for black here
and then we're going to bring our Knight
to d2 again we kind of talked about
where all of our ponds and pieces will
eventually end up he decided to already
bring his knight to d2 again we don't
bring our Knight to c3 because we do
want to solidify our pawn chain with our
pawn here on c3 and at the same time
it's it's always good to bring your
knight to d2 to also give a little bit
more support to your night here on f3
and since you're not immediately trying
to dominate the center then you don't
need your night here on c3 to attack and
defend this Center so it continues from
here with pawn to c5 and we bring our
pawn to e3 again starting to solidify
the center pawn structure that we talked
about and blacks going to bring his
Bishop to e7 getting ready to castle on
the King side and we bring our pawn to
c3 our pawn structure is complete as we
already talks about this kind of
triangle here
and after black castles then we bring
our Bishop to d3 and this is kind of
what we were talking about before these
are kind of where all your your pieces
belong now keep in mind that you may
have a slight variation depending on
where black place since two sides get to
play this may not occur all the time but
if blackboard just lets you play and
develop your pieces as you would want
this is kind of the setup that you want
you want your pawn chain to look like
this you obviously have your dark square
Bishop outside the pawn chain because we
developed it very early on then you have
your nights here on f3 and d2 with your
light toward Bishop very nicely placed
on this d3 square again this light
square Bishop is not attacking the F
square f7 square and at the same time
it's not directly attacking these Center
squares trying to control it again we're
just kind of waiting building up a
strong central control and then we're
going to decide what we want to do here
black decided to bring his Knight to d7
which kind of is the same as what we did
with our Knight to d2 I'm from here
white has an option obviously he wants
to eventually get his Queen and ball and
then he wants to connect his rooks but
why I decided to go ahead and play pawn
to h4 and what this says right off the
bat to black is saying you know what my
center is completely safe I don't need
to castle right now because my King is
safe and so what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to start to attack the King
side and that's exactly what white did
now in your own game this may not be the
best option for you black may castle on
the Queen side he may not castle at all
he may try to counter-attack before you
have a chance to do this but as you can
see there are a lot of different options
that white has in this case he already
built up a strong Center and he decided
to do is okay for him to go ahead
and attack on the kingside so from here
black played b6 I guess you didn't
really understand the threat that was
coming his way
white continued with Knight to e5 just
trying to break up some of this defense
that black has here and after black took
white took with his pawn on e5 attacking
this Knight here really trying to get
this Knight to move since again this
Knight is defending this pawn on age 7
he really wants to free up where his
LightSquared bishop here on d3 can
really start to get involved in this
attack here after the knight moves back
to d7 White's going to sacrifice his
bishop here on h7 or he really wants to
get this King out in the open they
really started to attack it so after the
King comes to age 7 and recaptures we
now bring our Queen to h5 so as you can
see we've really started to get you know
all of our pieces involved here and
again yes we did sacrificing Bishop at
the same time we have a lot more active
pieces as you can see here this rook
here on a 8 isn't doing anything this
Bishop more importantly isn't doing
anything here on c8 so yes we are down a
bishop but in the same time this
LightSquared Bishop for black isn't
doing anything and if as you can see our
dark squared Bishop is the bishop that's
usually not developed very often for
white and so we see the exact same thing
here for black his light square bishop
is not developed into the game and so
even though we're down a bishop since
his lights for a bishop isn't in the
game it's pretty much a wash because now
we have more active pieces his King is
out in the open and we started the
attack here so again I've talked about
it before it's not always how many
pieces you have
it's how many active pieces you have
attacking your opponent so in this case
although we are down in material he does
have pieces that are enacted and we have
much stronger attacking prowess than he
does so just keep that in mind whenever
you're playing chess if you can
sacrifice a bishop even though you're
down in material if they have an
inactive bishop on their side it may be
worth it so from here black brought his
King back to g8 and then white played
Knight to f3 and then after pawn to f6
we played or excuse me white played
Knight to g5 and you may ask why he did
this he really wants to get rid of this
pawn on h4 if he could he would just
take it away because then he would have
this really strong attack with this
Queen with this rook here on h1 you know
supporting it so he's going to do
whatever he can even if he has to
sacrifice another piece here on g5 to
get rid of this pawn here from h4 so
he's going to go ahead and give that
piece up and he's going to recapture
with his pawn on d5 so we've already
given up a bishop and a knight but at
the same time you can see a very
powerful attack coming here again we do
if we wanted to we could even castle on
the Queen side and get another rook
involved connect our rooks and really
start to attack but right away we have a
lot of the attacking power that we need
here with our Queen here on h5 our rook
here on h1 and this King very exposed
so from here black brought his rook to
h5 excuse me to fi and white brought his
Queen to h7 starting the attack
and after the king came to f7 white
continued to push his pawn up the board
checking there's not much room for black
to play here
he brought his King to he ate and after
we took white took on g7 the bishop came
to f8 and the Queen came back to h8 and
I'll just continue some of the moves
rook to g5 Queen to g8 rook coming down
to e5 capturing this knight on e5 the
King really trying to move away here
knowing that a lot of the pain is coming
and so now we brought the rook to h8
really starting to attack and the bishop
came to b7 trying to get involved in the
game but it's a little too late for this
LightSquared Bishop and after King to h7
then black resigned here there's just
too much for black to cope with and
again we have our dark square Bishop
very nicely placed here on e5 again this
all started with our Bishop here on f4
really putting a lot of pressure on
black and once now it's nicely placed on
e5 then it's really putting a lot of
pressure on black here you know again
we're attacking the king with our with
our queen but also attacking this Bishop
here on FA then indirectly attacking
this Queen here on d8 so even though
white is down quite a bit of material
black was forced to resign here because
he just didn't have the pieces to defend
and he didn't have as many active pieces
as wipe it in the attack so this is one
way you can play the London system again
I highly recommend it for people
especially those just getting into chess
very good way to learn how to develop
all your pieces properly and then you do
have a lot of different options
obviously in this game he chose to
completely dominate the king side but
you do have options you know
you can castle on the kingside you can
you know attack on the queenside
you do have a lot of options but I did
just want to show you a lot of people
think of this is a very passive opening
because you're not really staking claim
to anything in particular and you're not
really attacking right off the bat but I
did want to show since myself I'm an
aggressive player I didn't want to show
those players that wanted to try it out
and are a little bit more aggressive
that you do have options as far as you
know attacking completely on one side
and you do have a lot of different
options as far as you know sacrificing
but still getting a lot of aggressive
lines from all your pieces since all
your pieces are developed and they're in
the game very active so hope you guys
enjoyed the London system if you haven't
already please subscribe and I'll see
you guys in the next video thanks for
watching